[Musique]
poudre pistoles pépite pastilles
tablettes les chocolats dit à cuisson se
trouve en abondance dans les rayons des
épiceries chocolat pâtissier chocolat à
cuir chocolat pur ganache en fait c'est
plutôt un coup marketing que que
vraiment une spécificité de chocolat
selon le maître chocolatier yves bonneau
on peut cuisiner avec n'importe quel
chocolat et ce peu importe le
pourcentage de cacao est ce que le 77
mieux que 55 ou la poudre de cacao qui
est très amer et sèche ou un chocolat 70
80 ou 100 % de cacao mais il faut savoir
que tout ce cacao
on peut les employés le pourcentage nous
indique la quantité de cacao et de sucre
par exemple dans un chocolat 70%
vous avez 70 % de beurre et de pâte de
cacao
le reste c'est du sucre à partir de 70%
de cacao
on commence à avoir un impôt cola bien
structuré avec vraiment des goûts qui
peuvent être très puissant
on trouve sur l'emballage les
pourcentages mais pas toujours
sachez que pour les chocolats de type b
que on parle de me sucrer ou mi amer
cela varie de 57 à 67 % dans le cas des
poudres c'est 100 % de cacao
et qu'en est il de toutes ses formes
qu'on trouve en l'épicerie disons que là
la pistole comme on va fondre beaucoup
plus vite va être plus facile à
travailler
c'est vrai que le carré de chocolat et
on peut le casser on peut le coupé avec
un couteau
et c'est vrai que tous ces produits là
on peut les cuire mais ce qui influence
le goût et la texture c'est surtout la
teneur en cacao pour le démontrer
l'équipe dit bono a fait des copies cake
des brownies et des mousses déjà en
textures en couleurs on a des résultats
différents
la couleur est ce qu'elle est un rapport
avec le pourcentage ou pas du tout non
non ça veut rien dire en fait la couleur
et surtout donné par là
la fève de cacao selon que on peut avoir
un chocolat très clairs et qu'ils soient
très fort en cacao
[Musique]
c'est pas mauvais on a une belle
onctuosité
on pourra dire c'est que ce qu'on
retrouve par contre c'est ce goût de
poudre de cacao que nous avons là une m
une grosse amertume nous avons une
deuxième mousse qui est fait avec 1 52%
cacao dont qui est déjà plus ferme
délicieux on aimait ans derrière disons
déjà avec un chocolat qui est bien
présent et la dernière qui a encore un
petit peu plus ferme pourquoi parce
qu'on a un peu plus de chocolat de nom
c'est 1 70%
c'est plus lent c'est plus au rang des
plus grosses et savent exactement
souvent dans les chocolats on a des
chocolats à 80 90 % et on les trouve
très très dur très amer avec un goût de
brûlé
pourquoi parce que la grosse quantité
dans l'industrie on aurait fait très
fort et pour pour aller très vite pour
tuer tout ce qu'on veut tuer et puis on
remet de la vanille en mai tas de choses
avec pour essayer d'avoir un goût qui
soit un goût de chocolat
alors là on a trois brownies donc le
brownies qu'avec la poudre on va voir un
peu comme toutes les recettes
ça va être plus plus sec
[Musique]
voilà non mais ça se défait c'est donc
assez 52%
on va voir tout de suite on voit une
très large majorité c'est grâce à bagdad
et puis après évidemment là on aura sur
la 70% de cacao ou là on va voir cette
actualité
mais avec un groupe plus puissant plus
prononcé ça coûte d'abord chaque goutte
d'abord le chocolat oui quand vous avez
par exemple une recette avec 1 55 % de
cacao
cette même recette n'ira pas avec un
chocolat 85 % de cacao
pourquoi parce que par exemple le 85%
cacao beaucoup plus de beurre de cacao
donc on va avoir un problème de sur gras
c'est à dire qu'on mettra de la crème
qu'on avait dans la recette à 55 ce qui
fait qu'on va trancher la recette et on
aura un goût différent ça c'est sûr et
puis une texture différente jeu des
classes coque est ouvert le test de goût
de cupcake a donné les mêmes résultats
moi je pense que c'est plus intéressant
de faire une pâtisserie vous faire avec
du chocolat qu'avec de la poule on aura
plus de visites et plus de moelleux et
plus de goût les moins d'amertume
on ira chercher plus de de puissance et
de goût avec le 70 % un peu plus de
sucre est évidemment que 52 de ça reste
quand même du chocolat
au fond la règle est simple choisissez
un chocolat que vous aimez le plus
important est de cuisiner quand on parle
de chocolat est universel on s'en sert
pour à peu près tout
[Musique]